another brawl broke out at an
anti-vaccine protest this one is in the
uk
at the british equivalent of the
american fda we're going to look at the
video in a moment this took place at the
offices of the medicines and healthcare
products regulatory agency this is
basically the british fda
um the mhra is
responsible for ensuring
medicines and medical devices work
and are acceptably safe so very similar
to the us fda
this video we're going to look at this
brawl took place in canary wharf in
london the anti-vaccine protesters ended
up mostly fighting with police as they
showed up and tried to storm the
building the situation escalated when
the police started trying to push the
mob away from the building let's take a
look at the video if you're just
listening you won't get the full picture
but you will certainly be able to
realize it is total and absolute chaos
based on what you're about to hear
watching it just gives you
even more of the insane context
[Applause]
[Music]
this really is like a cult of sorts and
uh the latest i read is that four police
officers were hurt the entire you know
back the blue defend police stuff has
gone completely out the window in these
brawls from the very same people who
normally are saying but the police the
police we must keep them safe i guess
against vaccines it's all of a sudden
acceptable
not to prioritize the safety of police
officers and of course as the protesters
become increasingly unhinged and the
police are in danger the police start
taking out the batons and striking back
at the rioters and then the rioters use
that to their advantage they say look
the police were beating us willy-nilly
because we're concerned about vaccine
safety and of course it has nothing to
do with that whatsoever it's always the
exact same story when you see videos
like this
it's almost like these are coveted
enthusiasts like fans of the virus
protesting in favor of the pandemic it's
really crazy stuff made even crazier
when you consider some of the facts
first of all the vaccines are safe
secondly no one is being forced to get a
vaccine in the uk where this brawl took
place
it will be mandatory for home care
workers in england they will they have
to be vaccinated as of october
um english nightclubs and other venues
with large crowds are going to require
proof of full vaccination starting at
the end of this month at the end of
september that's really it for now like
what are they even really protesting and
of course individual businesses could
make it mandatory schools could make it
mandatory so that's
the sort of second piece of the idiocy
that's taking place here but then third
cases and deaths have both spiked
significantly in the uk
so why wouldn't people want to go and
get vaccinated and so this is
complicated enough the pandemic
without these people
but the future of the pandemic is
particularly uncertain thanks to them
tomorrow we're going to go over a new
report from the washington post
which says for scientists the path to
kovid's end game
remains uncertain and that's a
significant understatement kids going
back to school we're very quickly seeing
cases pop up
some schools already closed do we need
third doses in israel they're talking
about fourth doses modified for the
variants an insane amount of uncertainty
the people brawling with police against
vaccines out in front of the regulatory
agencies they're not helping to bring
this to a close any faster that's for
damn sure and they're only going to
extend how long this goes on and then
just to really illustrate for you
um how
uh significant
these delays are in getting people
vaccinated and in taking safety
precautions we're going to move on to
the next story about 15 miami educators
who are dead in 10 days from covid if
you ever feel like you just don't have
enough time to read all the books you
want to read you have to check out one
of my favorite apps called blinkist
blinkist takes thousands of popular
nonfiction books and distills each one
down into an e-book or audiobook that
you can get through in just 15 minutes
where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book just imagine how
you'll be able to expand your horizons
and knowledge by being able to soak up
all of the important insights from ten
different books
in an afternoon obviously it's perfect
for exposing yourself to a new book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for or you
can use it to revisit a book you've
already read or use it to preview a book
before you buy the full version and read
it i recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great stephen
hawking this is a book that i have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month and you get
the entire library but you can try it
totally free and get twenty five percent
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video